[Music]
welcome to Hannity and thank you for
being with us tonight coming up a
bombshell new twist in the Joe Biden
bribery and of course money laundering
allegation Scandal John Solomon will
join us with a full investigative report
also outrage is growing tonight
surrounding Joe Biden's plan to hand out
plea deals to the Al Qaeda five you know
the people responsible for 911 KSM
included but first we begin tonight in
Maui and Hawaii the tropical Hawaiian
Paradise in the middle of the Pacific
Ocean that will never be the same
horrific scenes of nothing but
Devastation are everywhere entire city
blocks Up in Smoke families burned alive
in their cars and in their homes so far
115 people are confirmed dead 850 plus
are still missing now two weeks after
the fire now it's possible that up to a
thousand people could have been killed
during this place we all probe and pray
that's not true including a
disproportionate number of children they
were sent home from school just as the
fire burned out of control and just to
give a sense of scale here less than 150
people were killed during Florida's last
Cat 4 hurricane and around 1300 people
were killed as a result of Hurricane
Katrina that was in New Orleans in the
aftermath that Katrina George W Bush was
excoriated days weeks months years after
the media the mob well for not visiting
soon enough not sending spending
sufficient time touring the devastation
but for some reason the media mob they
don't seem to care as much about Hawaii
and the pathetic response from Joe Biden
this is the equivalent of his Katrina
you wouldn't know it from the media mob
in their fawning coverage think about
this the president refused to visit Maui
until spending multiple weeks on not one
but two separate vacations two now first
during a 10-day getaway at the Beach in
Delaware where he struggled to move his
speech chair well Biden couldn't even be
bothered to comment on the disaster
literally shouting at the media mob his
friends no as they were asking for
common a sympathetic word or remarks for
the people of Hawaii and over the
weekend Biden arrived in Lake Tahoe for
more rest and relaxation at a luxury
Waterfront Mansion of one of his
billionaire rich friends it wasn't until
yesterday afternoon that Biden finally
took that short flight
from Nevada to visit Maui in person on
the ground while Joe's motorcade was
greeted by locals lining the streets
with signs blasting Biden's response
shouting go home Joe Biden and during
his brief remarks by the way Biden
appeared completely unprepared apathetic
and as per usual befuddled and Confused
take a look Brian chance our Senator
Senator Maisie by the way basically I
told my granddaughter whose name is
Maisie as well she said that's why I
like her anyway
but her name is maize as well
and uh and Jill
takuda and mayor Rick Bassin uh Rick
when we talked on the phone I never you
look like you played
in a defensive tackle for uh I don't
know who but it was somebody good
I want to thank you for your leadership
and this unimaginable during this
unimaginal tragedy tragedy one called it
the diamond in the rough of Hope
another referred to fire cannot reach
its root with his fire cannot reach its
roots
can you not see the cognitive decline is
getting dramatically worse now it also
gets worse in this case Biden then you
know try to impress Maui's victims with
a a tall tale about how he almost lost
his Corvette during what was a small
house fire that was an extinguished in
about 20 minutes watch this
I don't want to
compare difficulties with it we have a
little sense still and I most like to
lose the home
years ago now 15 years ago I was in
Washington doing Meet the Press
it was a sunny Sunday
lightning struck at home
on a little Lake that's outside of our
home uh like a big pond
and hit the wire came up underneath our
home into the heating does the air
conditioning
make a long story short
I almost lost my wife
my 67 Corvette
and my cat
so we have all these people dead nearly
a thousand people still missing
thousands and thousands have lost
everything and Biden is talking about
his personal Trauma from nearly losing a
67 Corvette a fire that was a minor
extinguished in 20 minutes in case uh
Joe's disgusting treatment of his own
seventh grandchild did include you in
this guy is totally self-absorbed
completely heartless and here he is
laughing about how hot the ground was in
Maui really Joe take a look you guys
catch the boots out here
ah crowd man all told Biden was in Maui
for less than six hours before getting
on Air Force One that you pay for and of
course carbon emissions that we all pay
for right Joe and headed back to his
vacation at Lake Tahoe but before he
left Biden did manage to get in well
what might be a short nap or maybe I
should just say nodding off or maybe
just resting his tired old eyes for
about oh 12 seconds and then struggling
to keep his eyes open staring off into
the distance again befuddled bewildered
Dazed and Confused it was well passed
Biden's Betty by time on the east coast
and he was primed and ready for his
Standard 12 hours or so of sleep and of
course the people of Maui have had weeks
of sleepless nights their loved ones are
missing their homes are and businesses
destroyed their government has failed
them and according to reports on the
ground the Biden Administration has been
missing in action the entire time the
federal response from FEMA has been
pretty much non-existent the white White
House is offering a mere 700 dollars per
family which kind of pales in comparison
to the twenty six hundred dollars per
person the Administration has already
doled out to Ukraine in Maui local
officials previously obsessed with water
conservation they delayed the release of
critical water from reservoirs for five
long hours during the height of the fire
and meanwhile the extensive warning
system in Maui that stayed silent it was
never turned on and Hawaii's electric
company failed to maintain their grid
despite prior concerns about sparking a
wildfire and the company was sidetracked
of course with expensive green new
energy deal projects a top priority for
that state now the disaster in Hawaii
shouldn't be political the mob and the
media the Democrats anybody with a
conscience a heart and of souls should
be outraged they should be demanding
accountability from State local and
federal leaders but that isn't and
hasn't happened why because the
politicians the bureaucrats have fault
they're all Democrats in this case and
as we know by now Democrats they almost
always get a free pass but at least the
people of Maui can rest easy knowing
that Joe's 67 Corvette where of course
he was parking uh next to his top secret
classified documents was spared during
the small electrical fire at his house
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else